[Musik]
am 15 August 2022 feierte Indien den 75
jahrestag seiner Unabhängigkeit Indien
ist nicht irgendein Land auf der
Weltkarte sprechen über ein Land in dem
fast 20 Prozent der gesamten
Weltbevölkerung leben und das im Jahr
2023 China als bevölkerungsreiches Land
der Erde überholen wird der enormen
Bedeutung Chinas in allen globalen
Angelegenheiten sind wir uns ja
hinreichend bewusst aber wenn einer von
fünf Menschen weltweit in Indien lebt
bedeutet das natürlich das auch Indien
für die Zukunft von uns allen viel
wichtiger werden könnte als wir uns das
heute denken indien ist ein unglaublich
vielfältiges Land nach
volkszählungsdaten werden zum Beispiel
140 verschiedene Sprachen gesprochen
davon gilt nicht weniger als 22 als
Nationalsprachen und sind durch die
Verfassung anerkannt neben seiner
Vielfalt hat Indien noch ein weiteres
Merkmal es ist traditionell eines der
bürokratischsten Länder der Welt
vielleicht ist das eine der Gründe warum
ist auch immer ein sehr armes Land ist
in der aktuell unruhigen Phase der
globalen Entwicklung könnte sich das
Schicksal und die Rolle in den sie doch
massiv ändern und damit auch die Zukunft
der Weltwirtschaft denn es gibt da eine
Frage die sich immer mehr Experten
stellen und sie bezieht sich wahnsinnig
nicht nur auf die top position bei der
Bevölkerungszahl sondern die
wirtschaftliche Bedeutung könnte Indien
das neue China werden hört sich
interessant an nicht wahr dann lasst uns
loslegen
ein Motor der nur schwer in Gang kommt
[Musik]
im letzten Jahrzehnt ist die extreme
Armut in Indien drastisch zurückgegangen
nach Angaben der Weltbank hat sich der
Anteil von Menschen in Armut von 22,5%
im Jahr 2011 auf 10,2% in 2019 mehr als
halbiert seht euch an
der Anteil der extremarmen Sulger auf
nur 2% gefallen sein und das
Entwicklungsprogramm der Vereinten
Nation das nach etwas anderen Kriterien
nicht nur monetären misst kommt zu einem
ebenso deutlichen Ergebnis die UN
spricht in ihrem neuesten globalen
Armutsbericht davon ist aktuell nur
16,2% der indischen Bevölkerung in Armut
leben noch vor 15 Jahren waren es
55%. das heißt das 415 Millionen in der
in dieser Zeitspanne der Armut entkommen
sind das ist natürlich eine riesiger
Erfolg aber aus einer ganz anderen
Perspektive betrachtet kann man trotzdem
sagen das ist für das riesige Land nicht
gerade prima gelaufen ist
denn als Indien 1974 unabhängig wurde
betrug sein Prokopfeinkommen etwa 18%
des globalen Durchschnitts heute 75
Jahre später ist dieser Anteil in
Prozent in etwa gleich geblieben mit
anderen Worten obwohl Indien damals ein
bitterarmes Land war und seither intern
enorme Fortschritte gemacht hat so hat
es doch in mehr als 7 Jahrzehnten seinen
Rückstand gegenüber den Industrieländern
nicht in geringsten aufholen können die
Konsequenz ist Indien ist zweifellos
nicht mehr das Armen Haus der Welt aber
kollektiver Wohlstand hat sich dort denn
noch nicht bereit gemacht lass mich ein
paar Beispiele anführen laut der letzten
nationalen Haushaltsbefragung von 2020
haben in Indien z.B 9,5 % der
Bevölkerung ein Computer zur Verfügung
nur 18,6 Prozent der Haushalte haben
eine Waschmaschine und nur 8% besitzen
ein Auto diese datenspiegeln die
Realität eines Landes wieder dass ein
wirtschaftliches Potenzial noch nicht
erreicht hat tatsächlich sind in den
letzten Jahren viele multinationale
Unternehmen in Indien gescheitert weil
die Mittelschicht relativ klein ist
einem globalen Maßstab gesehen auch noch
relativ arm einer der jüngsten Fälle war
der von Ford der Automobilkonzern
kündigte an den indischen Markt
aufzugeben nach den er mehr als zwei
Milliarden Dollar Verlust angehäuft
hatte General Motors und Harley Davidson
hatten zuvor ähnliche Maßnahmen
ergriffen ihr seht also die indische
Bevölkerung mag gigantisch groß sein ihr
Nachholbedarf bei Konsumgütern und den
Lebensstandard sicher auch aber der
dortige macht für Automobile oder eben
dicke Motorräder bleibt winzig okay
vielleicht liegt es auch daran dass man
mit Mopeds oder günstigen indischen
Motorrädern im Gefühl der dortigen
Städte einfach deutlich besser
durchkommt die vielleicht deutlichsten
Daten bietet ein Vergleich mit China
bis 1990 hatten beide Länder ungefähr
das gleiche mediane Einkommen aber
seitdem hat sich einiges getan seit 1990
hat sich in Indien das Foto
Inlandsprodukt pro Kopf um das
Sechsfache erhöht das klingt nicht
schlecht aber Chinas
Bruttoinlandsprodukt pro Kopf hat sich
in diesen drei Jahrzehnten um das
40-fache erhöht dabei sprechen wir hier
von einer relativ guten Zeit für Indien
das Land hatte 1991 eine schwere Krise
durchgemacht entsprechend musste es
viele Reformen umsetzen um sich der Welt
zu öffnen und das hat seine Wirtschaft
angekurbelt aber wie ihr seht ist der
Rückstand trotzdem enorm Indien war
nicht in der Lage das industrielle
Entwicklungsmodell zu reproduzieren ist
andere wirtschaftliche
Erfolgsgeschichten in Asien kennzeichnet
also die von Japan Südkorea Singapur und
vor allem die von China seit 2021 weicht
die Enttäuschung jedoch dem Optimismus
plötzlich ist Indien wieder angesagt
Privatinvestoren Portfolio Manager und
sogar große multinationale Unternehmen
richten ihre Augenmerk auf diesen Markt
und die Frage steht im Raum was genau
ist der Grund für diesen Wandel warum
wird dieses Land plötzlich die Fantasie
von größten Wirtschaftswissenschaften
Investoren weltweit und die wichtigste
Frage von allen könnte in den
wirtschaftlich wirklich so etwas wie das
neue China werden also sehen wir mal
nach
Tempowechsel
indien hat vor kurzem Großbritannien als
fünftgrößte Volkswirtschaft der Welt
überholt es ist beim Wert ist eine
börsennotierten Unternehmen das
viertgrößte Land und steht nach den USA
und China an dritter Stelle was die
Anzahl der Einhörner angeht für
diejenigen unter euch die mit diesem
Business-Mode Begriff nichts anfangen
können Unicorns also Einhörner nennt man
Startup Unternehmen mit einem Wert von
über eine Milliarde Dollar plötzlich
sehen wir Nachrichten wie diese Indien
wird in diesem Jahr wo die am
schnellsten wachsende der großen
Volkswirtschaften sein um diese
Veränderung zu veranschaulichen lasst
uns doch mal kurz nach Tamil nado
schauen einem Bundesstaat im Süden des
Landes hier stellt der indische konstant
Tata Komponenten für die neuesten
iPhones her damit wird in den erstmals
in einer der komplexesten Lieferketten
der Welt integriert das ist sozusagen
das Pilotprojekt weil der Entwicklung
die in Zukunft wirklich wichtig werden
könnte
ich glaube fest daran dass dies das
Jahrzehnt in dem es wird und das ist
nicht nur so daher geredet große
indische Konzerne planen in den nächsten
Jahren mehr als 250 Milliarden Dollar zu
investieren um ihre
Produktionskapazitäten im Land zu
erhöhen doch wie wir gesehen haben boten
die letzten Jahre noch nichts was uns
wirklich vom Stuhl gehauen hätte warum
also halten so viele Experten ist
dennoch für wahrscheinlich ist der
wirtschaftlich auch schon Indien
unmittelbar bevorsteht
es gibt da vier Schlüsselfaktoren vier
große Gelegenheiten dank derer Indien so
etwas wie das China das 21 jahrhunderts
werden könnte Faktor Nummer eins ist das
in den letzten Jahren ein einheitlicher
nationaler Markt entstanden ist erinnert
ihr euch dass ich anfangs von der
erstaunlichen sprachlichen Vielfalt in
den gesprochen habe ja sie ist aber
zugleich ein Indiz dafür dass man in
gewisser Weise bei Indien bisher nicht
von einem einzigen großen Markt sprechen
konnte sondern eher von vielen extrem
fragmentierten regionalen Märkten dieses
Phänomen hat natürlich den größten
Vorteil bedeutender Unternehmen
eingeschränkt doch hier hat sich was
getan und tut sich weiterhin in den
letzten Jahren hat die Regierung eine
einheitliche Umsatzsteuer und viele
weitere Regeln für das ganze Land
eingeführt auch die
Verkehrsinfrastruktur wurde stark
verbessert so wurde z.B das nationale
Straßennetz seit 2014 und 50% ausgebaut
neue inlandsflugverbindungen ermöglicht
eine Verdoppelung der Passagierzahlen
und einen Anstieg des Kraftverkehrs
umfasst 50% ganz ähnlich verhält es sich
hinter der Kommunikationssektor das
Ergebnis ist ein zunehmend integrierter
Markt mit etwa 1,4
Verbrauchern der ist Firmen ermöglicht
viel effizienter zu arbeiten und die
enormen Größenvorteil dieses Marktes zu
nutzen
kurz gesagt gilt jetzt die Masse machts
zweitens hat die Regierung die
Verwaltung und das Finanzsystem
weitgehend digitalisiert von der
biometrischen Identifizierung bis zu
einem nationalen digitalen
Zahlungssystem namens ubi immer mehr
einst komplizierte Vorgänge werden von
den Internisten ruckzuck am Mobiltelefon
erledigt dadurch können Dinge viel
schneller und billiger abgewickelt
werden als bisher zum Beispiel zahlt die
Regierung geht staatliche Hilfen über
die digitales Systeme aus wodurch
Bürokratie abgebaut wurde und
sichergestellt ist dass das Geld auch
wirklich die vorgesehenen Empfänger
erreicht liebe Leute wir sprechen hier
von einem System über das in den letzten
63 Monaten fast 200 Milliarden Dollar an
950 Millionen Menschen ausgezahlt wurden
zweimal mehr als die Europäische Union
Einwohner zählt eine großartiger
Fortschritt vor allem wenn man bedenkt
dass bis zur Einführung dieser digitalen
sofortüberweisungen ein großer Teil
dieser Geldern nie bei den eigentlichen
unterstützungsempfängern ankam sondern
unterwegs sind endlosen bürokratischen
Prozessen und korruptionslümpfen alle
Art versickerte die Digitalisierung der
Verwaltung und der Finanzströme hat
nicht nur dazu für das indische Familien
nun ihre Zahlungen in Windeseile
erhalten sie hat auch einen riesigen
Sektor von wie verrückt wachsenden
Technologie Startups angeschoben sie
bietet IT-Profis wie fintech Cracks
jetzt jede Menge Jobs kommen wir zum
dritten wichtigen Faktor dieser heißt
China ja richtig gehört der große
Konkurrent China
[Musik]
die euch schon in früheren Videos sich
auf dieser Politik erzählt haben die
Links findet ihr unten in der
Beschreibung macht das reicht der Mitte
gerade nicht die besten Zeiten durch
wieder in wirtschaftliche noch in
politischer Sicht der Zusammenbruch des
Immobilienmarktes und die schlechten
Beziehungen zu den USA lassen viele
multinationale Unternehmen nach
Alternativen Ausschau halten und Indien
scheint die eine perfekter Kandidat zu
sein findet ihr nicht auch wenn das Land
lockt mit einer enormen großen zu dem
sehr jungen Bevölkerung und ziemlich
niedrigen Löhnen und um mehr Unternehmen
anzulocken hat die indische Regierung
einen 26 Milliarden dollarplan für
multi-nationale Unternehmen aufgelegt
diese sollen damit vor allem Fabriken im
Lande errichten Unternehmen wie Samsung
und Fox Konto nutzen diese Anreise
bereits und bauen ihre Präsenz in Indien
aus
und den vierten und vorerst letzten
Faktor finden wir erstaunlicherweise gar
nicht in Indien selbst sondern im großen
Rest der Welt die Rede ist von der
riesigen indischen expert Gemeinde also
Menschen die aus Indien stammen oder
deren familiäre Wurzeln dort liegen es
handelt sich hierbei um mehr als 30
Millionen Menschen die allein 2021 fast
90 Milliarden Dollar ein Überweisungen
nach Indien geschickt haben darunter
sind natürlich auch viele arme Schlucker
die etwa auch Baustellen in den
Golf-Staaten schuften aber in manch
anderen Ländern sind diese
Gemeinschaften relativ wohl haben nach
volkszählungsdaten aus dem Vereinigten
Staaten ist die indische Community die
reichste ethnische Gruppe in den USA wir
sprechen hier von einem
durchschnittlichen Haushaltseinkommen
von 120 000 $ und tatsächlich sind laut
einer aktuellen Studie der Standard
Universität und 9% der Gründer der 500
US-amerikanischen Einhörner in Indien
geboren zudem finden wir Angehörige
dieser Gemeinschaft an der Spitze nicht
weniger großer multi-nationale
Unternehmen wie Microsoft Google Channel
und die Leute solche Menschen können
jede Eigenkapital und Einfluss aufbieten
um in ihrem Herkunftsland zu investieren
ach ja und auch der neue britische
Premierminister regissonak ist zwar in
England geboren aber indischer
Abstammung und ebenfalls ziemlich reich
diese führenden Köpfe unter den
indischen expert sind auch eine wichtige
Lobby für die Modernisierung der Gesetze
und Institutionen vor Ort sozusagen aus
eigenem Interesse aber auch dank eigener
Erfahrung wenn wir jetzt diese vier
Zutaten diese vier Schlüsselfaktoren in
einem Mixer geben haben wir das was
viele Experten als das perfekte Rezept
für Indien ansehen um in den nächsten
Jahren durch zu starten und das neue
China zu werden so kann in dem das neue
trendland werden und zugleich die neue
große Fabrik für global gefragt waren
und Dienstleistungen es könnte der
globale Joker sein damit die Produkten
weltweit wieder steigt die Kosten sinken
und damit auch die Inflation aber
andererseits vielleicht geht gerade die
Indien Begeisterung mit uns etwas durch
denn dieses Ziel in der Realität zu
erreichen ist auch nicht gerade im
Handumdrehen erledigt deshalb schauen
wir uns jetzt auch die bremsfaktoren die
unsere subtrope stufenen Blütenträume
von eben durchkreuzen könnten
[Musik]
Indiens anderes Gesicht
es ist eine Sache eine Chance zu haben
aber eine ganz andere sie zu nutzen
bisher gab es viele Momente und
Gelegenheiten als Indien bereit zu sein
schienen durchzustarten und dann ist der
Elan doch wieder versandet um einen
Scheitern von Indiens großen Relaunch zu
verhindern muss das Land nämlich auch
hier große Probleme lösen erstens das
Bildungsniveau ist im Großen und Ganzen
lausig Angaben aus dem Jahr 2017 zufolge
waren etwa 25% der indischen
Jugendlichen zwischen 14 und 18 Jahren
nicht in der Lage basistexte in ihrer
eigenen Sprache zu lesen und mit dem
Rechnen Stand ist nicht viel besser über
die Hälfte war nicht in der Lage eine
Division durchzuführen zweiter negativ
Faktor der Staat ist nach wie vor ein
Schwergewicht in der Wirtschaft trotz
aller Fortschritte ist in den immer noch
ein sehr bürokratisches Land und seine
staatseigenen Großunternehmen sind
furchtbar ineffizient um euch eine
Hausnummer zu nennen im Index der
wirtschaftlichen Freiheit liegt in den
auf Platz 131 und das ist wahrlich keine
Ruhmesblatt 3 sind die öffentlichen
Haushalte in keinem guten Zustand die
Staatsverschuldung liegt bereits 92% des
Bruttoinlandsprodukts und der Haushalt
kommt nicht aus den roten Zahlen heraus
und das gilt nur für die zentrale
Regierung denn die Kunden einige
Regionalregierungen stehen praktisch am
Rande des Abgrunds
[Musik]
und schließlich gibt es noch einen
weiteren großen bremskloß in viele
vielleicht gar nicht auf dem Radar haben
Frauen sind doch immer weitgehend vom
Arbeitsmarkt ausgeschlossen die
erwerbungsquote von Frauen ist sogar
niedriger als er notorisch patriarchalen
Ländern die Saudi-Arabien und das
schmäler natürlich die
Haushaltseinkommen lässt die Talente von
100 Millionen Frauen verkümmern aber
damit zunächst einmal genug wir haben
jetzt im Schnelldurchlauf die positiven
und negativen Aspekt eines riesigen
Landes betrachtet das vor seiner größten
Chance zu stehen scheint jeweils so alt
Politik werden weiterhin eine
aufmerksames Auge auf Indien werfen und
natürlich auf seine Aufholjagd gegenüber
seinem Rivalen China und nun seid ihr an
der Reihe die Diskussion zu eröffnen
meint ihr Indien könnte das neue China
werden wird man auf dem indischen in der
Lage sein alle brisanten Probleme zu
lösen aktuell hatte indische Präsidentin
der Modi versprochen dem Land in 25
Jahren einen Entwicklungsschub zu geben
doch kann ihm dieser Kapitale Durchbruch
gelingen schreibt uns bitte in den
Kommentaren was ihr darüber denkt wenn
ihr dieses Video interessant es gibt ihm
doch ein Like und lasst uns auf eine
kleine Spende über den Link in der
Beschreibung zu kommen gerade in der
Weihnachtszeit während dies unsere
Herzen ganz besonders und vergesst auf
jeden Fall auch nicht visualpolitik zu
abonnieren natürlich mit Glocke macht's
gut bis zum nächsten Mal und namaste
[Musik]